[Musik]
Ich habe auf
dem Feld nachgesehen, es sah aus wie eine Million
Millionen und eine Hälfte Menschen.
Wir haben eine ganz besondere Beziehung.
Tatsächlich werde ich dieses kleine Stück
[Musik]
Schuppen bekommen.
Meine Verwaltung hat mehr
als
fast erreicht  jede Regierung in der
Geschichte unseres Landes
Amerika ist so wahr,
hat diese Reaktion nicht erwartet, aber das ist
okay,
sie werden mit Feuer und Wut
konfrontiert werden [Musik] kofi ko fifi ko fife
was bedeutet das, genannt faffi, das
musst du nehmen  aus, bitte,
du kannst es einfach ausziehen, wie viele
Meter bist du weg,
und dann sehe ich das Desinfektionsmittel,
wo es es
in einer Minute, einer Minute, ausschaltet, und gibt es eine
Möglichkeit, so etwas
durch Injektion ins Innere zu machen oder
oder jetzt sie  sagen, ich bin immun, ich kann fühlen, ich
fühle mich so stark, ich werde
in dieses Publikum gehen, ich werde
dort hineingehen, ich werde jeden in diesem
[Musik]
-Publikum küssen